hey I'm raw strengths and needs channel
roughs all you can follow me on my
social at Roscoe's hello my name is
Anthony Jones you can follow me at robot
pencil and all that
today we're drawing Dragon Ball Z
characters from memory as far as I know
that's what the shows pretty much I
watched journal Z one of the kid a lot
whenever I teach all I use is like
Dragon Ball our alliances yeah
can we switch sides now I decide I want
to just like over there this has always
been my side I've no idea of someone
else then gotta get that side the
bubblegum honky food right Vegeta oh
yeah okay I try to be subversive and not
have empowering up you give Vegeta
whatever attitude speaks to you I'm
gonna have a huffy Vegeta oh wait is it
there like multiple go cous which one
are we drawing I think we're just
drawing the base grown up Goku
majin buu was like one of my favorite
arcs in Dragon Ball Z I think I stepped
out of Dragon Ball Z during this age
he's got a very angular body angular
face much like my own head oh I got a
video reference right in front of me it
looks like so you never watch Dragon
Ball I watched some Dragon Balls but
definitely not enough to like to call
myself a fan through social osmosis I
know quite a lot about Dragon Ball Z but
I know that they need to collect the
Dragon Balls to make their wish come
true
wait are we sure this isn't pokemon no I
have no idea what he wears like a cape
all right cool
so it's gonna give on the cape and I'm
gonna give him some muscle and he has
pants does he have a shirt on I don't
know I - shirtless then we're going for
it yeah I haven't watched Dragon Ball Z
since college so this is gonna be real
interesting when do you think I went to
college Jackie
17:53 the same age that Lincoln was born
well what's your favorite Dragon Ball Z
episode oh man maybe a Dragon Ball Kai
episode where they assembled five
episodes into one and they removed all
the panning shots of like lakes
and some like grass wrestling and a few
I have a lot of be role in that
fictional universe I think in antennae
there's a real stereotype of around
aliens and yeah from different worlds
that they all have antennas I feel like
we need to break that stereotype I know
he's wearing like an orange jumpsuit
right with a belt
form and function over fashion in this
show remind me why were they fighting
all the time cuz they're all fighting
over the Dragon Ball you gotta catch
them all
you got a catch mall unlike other shows
that might use that motto I don't want
you to forget about Vegeta's intense
widow's peak oh yes thank you that is
the key to this character Vegeta is what
introduced me to what a widow's peak was
yeah he's really he's really got it
going when I was growing up I watched a
lot of dragon OC
how old are you when you were watching
that stuff I was like six seven eight it
was it was the thing I think what I
loved about Dragon Ball was that it was
like it was kind of like a soap opera
for children a soap opera for children
does he work gloves I feel like he wears
some butler gloves like white gloves
yeah when you're punching so many things
don't you have to protect your hands
doesn't like boxing gloves sure giving
foxy did you give him boxing glove okay
keep it on 99% sure he does not have
boxing club oh he has a thing I don't
know what it says
doesn't he have a logo on his shirt I'm
just gonna draw a circle with the heart
in it oh let me ask are you putting him
in like the pink shirt Bermuda shorts
Vegeta or no I was like summer vacation
but yeah that's one of my favorite
things about Dragon bows the episodes is
that they would do these random so I
mean it's not my favorite it annoyed the
hell out of me as a kid but it's really
funny looking back that it would be like
the planets at stake and didn't you
wonder how like yeah sure Robi was
getting his driver's license no nobody
yeah sure Robi it was a joke that's like
how many Dragon Ball Z characters does
it take to screw in a light bulb
I don't know only takes one it takes
five episodes to do it oh there is this
whole arc with Goku holding up a spear
bomb yeah and for like five six seven
episodes so I remember Dragon Ball Z
mostly from the Super Nintendo game
there's a Super Nintendo oh hell yeah
there it was it like a fighting game
yeah it's like Street Fighter
but it's mostly just you throwing giant
fireballs and energy at each other that
sounds great
yeah that's all I want to do in real
life you just want to throw giant
fireballs at me yeah Jackie I remember
he was weirdly small in the show he's
small but he's also just like really
thin and delicate looking yeah I
remember wasn't super intimidated by him
when I first saw him because he was
standing next to like the big guys yeah
that's the whole ball big yeah supposed
to be like a week looking prints but
then he's the strongest one Toriyama was
good at that kind of thing I like that
if I was like in the you know design
room and they're like Anthony what do
you think we should do with this
character first of all I'd be like he
needs more muscles muscles what and then
they'll probably would be rightfully
angry enough all right the next step we
need to spread that pink like all over
the place are you gonna make him gloat
how does it make them glow I'm gonna
make it a little
oh boy cuz when they do the screaming
thing when they scream at each other
when they scream at each other they glow
don't they I think so all right I will
try to make them glow
what's his color scheme is he blue and
red bluing hello
well yeah he's like yellow and the
version I'm drawing he's got to like say
I remove it you know what I mean my god
I can't fly can't remember his colors I
was so confident going in I'm like oh I
know he looks like he's just like a big
just know that my design is inspired by
your work so if I am wrong everybody I'm
not the blade whoa and then if you're
wrong on your end then you are
detectable boy when they're like juice
enough to become super science and their
juice enough you know what I mean you
know what I'm talking about Jackie don't
pretend like you don't know what I'm
talking about
say Goku is juice enough don't like
rocks and stuff like float oh yeah
whenever they're juicing up stop saying
juice enough juicing up Jackie baby I
gave my guy black nipples back why does
he have nipples I think so I think so
dude Dragon Ball Z matured they went
nipples nice
oh I remember I think he has a
simpleness forehead like m4 majin buu
hey Cody
hey what does the scanner say about his
power level its over 9000
time to color dodge ready that lighting
in there oh snap
and now that is so good I know if he
looks better look at all that good stuff
is getting out of there see if the kite
know check it out that's the secret to
art that is this guitar just color dodge
everything that's all you need a de
facto dodge I didn't get to draw the
glow Kevin you didn't get to draw the
glow I didn't get to draw the glow what
happened I passed out in the middle of
the video for some reason I didn't
notice any of that yeah I you were
really into you I was really in the
middle I know it's okay I'm fine okay I
might die in us up in a couple seconds
okay how do you think you did mm Jack
you know i'ma call mine okay cool
how do you think you did I think I
capture the essence pretty well I'm
missing a lot of details I forgot to put
sandals on them it's another impression
to stick one I'm here for it how did you
do pretty good pretty close Vegeta with
some Brent flair in there I feel good
about the blue spandex I feel good about
the yellow armor pieces but there's just
little Maggie things that feel off that
I just can't figure out right now how do
you think you did I think I did pretty
okay his hair is blond because he was
yelling okay but I think it is black
normally yes yes I didn't get to draw
the glow so now just you know looks like
crap I'm sure it doesn't look like crap
looks like frat Jackie throw it in the
crap settle down can I say crap sure
looks like crap
whoa so cool this is way more cute this
is
oh person note it's a cake I should have
had a cake yeah dude come on
this stuff is great into this oh my god
this is really how that looks just like
him you gave him elf ears for sonic in
male fears yeah what did the kind of
years he has I don't think so I know he
is he wait
oh I'm just now remembering they're like
aliens right okay looks like a zombie
version of Majnu
I think so too but you know in a really
good way no this is amazing actually I
was expecting you were gonna make your
character really adorable you know what
a good anime face really yeah and you
know what else I'm gonna say it looks
nothing like Kevin it does not look like
heaven at all I like the boxing gloves I
think that he should have boxing gloves
normally so his hip flap things also
protect his junk he's just got a full
like beetle wings protecting his whole
area yeah okay so I kind of got there
was a beetle that's it a beetle wing I
kind of got that on his belly
protecting his abdomen but you got to
protect the crotch I blame Ross with him
you didn't give me anything I was like
he had he had this yeah back yet an
antenna yeah we're really off are we
Dragon Ball Z fans nice all right all
right looks good looks good
the thing about his spiky hair I knew it
wasn't spiky all the way I knew that
yeah I knew it we got like a like a
thick yeah it's like designed
purposefully in a really cool way that's
got to be held to animate though cuz
it's very specific yeah I'm glad we
didn't do it me watching this as a kid I
haven't seen this character for over two
decades and so the things you do
remember at the kid components of good
design yeah number the pink
I remember the M and it means that the
designer probably put that in there for
us to remember it and so two decades
later we're gonna Busby John majin buu
so now that's a great point absolutely I
personally didn't grow up with it but it
impacted a whole generation of people it
really did it's like pokemons it's so
popular that even I know majin buu and I
think majin buu is very cute I don't
know who majin buu is get it
[Music]